je viens du futur
si vous ne m'écoutez pas
voilà ce qui va se passer
oui ou non structurées
sa centrale va exposer papa ne vais pas
me faire croire que toutes les
catastrophes qui ont lieu dehors sont
toutes de ma faute si tu construis ta
centrale voilà ce qui va se passer
tous les 70 ans le nuage tue 50 % de la
population à chacun de ses passages et
bien drôle à
sacrifier mon père pour sauver le monde
c'est pas juste je suis sûr qu'il peut
changer
ces conflits sont notre priorité
ces actions peuvent briser le continuum
espace temps
et de nouveaux types qui ont débarqué le
clodo a disparu je suis perdue
[Musique]
3-2 surtout des faits mais ouvert
la comptable c'était ça déchire
milan et protéger le cours du temps si
on perd tout le monde perd
tout a une fin le monde
vous inquiétez pas il y aura pas le
temps de me voir venir
[Musique]